Harry I think one of Paul's failings as
a preacher is that he tends to use
illustrations and analogies that fall
apart halfway through and when he thinks
he's clarifying an issue he sometimes
confuses it here he begins chapter 7
dealing with the same issues we've been
dealing with which is how does the law
work how does said work what's Christian
freedom and talks about marriage in ways
which indicate that he hasn't been
married at least for a long time what do
you think about this illustration
analogy you know the analogy limps here
at the beginning of chapter 7 I think
you have to keep in mind where Paul is
finally going in order to say what point
he's he's striking here and chapter 7 is
where the argument about the law
culminates and what he wants to affirm
is that the law is good and holy and
true but it's inadequate to to do the
deed of relating human beings to God I
think that's his fundamental line and
he's also just come off of the metaphor
of slavery and freedom yeah
and he says said that we are slaves to
righteousness which in his mind is a
good thing now picking up on slavery and
bondage he uses the image of matrimony
and how a person in matrimony is bound
as long as the spouse is alive and the
spouse dies then the person right free
right so what what he wants to say is
that the law somehow functioned as
spouse and the spouse died and therefore
it doesn't work that doesn't work you
know every spouse I know is annoyed by
this no Christian freedom yes so you can
see where he wants to go and you know
you can see that the all the elements
that they had to develop an analogy but
it just doesn't fit so he does this this
business then moves on rather quickly to
a kind of psychological analysis of of
the law and how it works for the rest of
chapter 7 and it really comes in two
parts
starts out with one of his rhetorical
questions and verse seven what then
should we say that the law is sin no he
doesn't want to say that by no means yet
if it had not been for the law I would
not have known sin so it's
thing that he had hinted at back there
and check whether exactly that the law
somehow can be an instrument of of
sinfulness yeah but it isn't itself the
cause of C and I like to say that this
is rather like the the cookie jar of
theology you tell a little child
don't put your heritage are absolutely
in that guarantee the child is going to
go exactly I think has that same time or
the briar patch whatever you do throw me
in the briar yeah so Paul has that kind
of AB psychological and I think but but
he also has a scriptural context in mind
too and as we've seen him do in several
other cases he's alluding to scriptural
narrative and I think what he has in
mind here yes the Genesis soderbergh an
utter true
and he's importing into the Genesis
story elements of the Ten Commandments
and so he he does so through a
first-person narrative and this I think
we have to recognize is another literary
trope and a lot of ink has been spilled
in the history of interpretation of
Romans on the I huge amount in Romans 7
yeah 7 and 9 is Paul really revealing
himself and talking about his interior
personal struggles yeah
or is he using the AI as just a perso
one if one had not one it's the latter
yeah Roma and I think they the
experience of the eye here was shaped
more by a reading of Genesis than by
Paul's own personal life story and so
when he says I once I was once alive
apart from the law this is verse 9 you
know when the commandment came sin
revived and I died and the very
commandment the promise life proved to
be death to me I think the I here was
really Adam yeah the Adam that he was
talking about in the Adam Christ
typology and carpet ago and the command
is don't eat of the the fruit of the
tree of the knowledge and you suddenly
think about that promise is something
good and it delivers something that here
so I think he has that
in mind but he gentleman teachers he
generalizes from that biblical story
using this personal language in order to
make it generally applicable experience
yeah invites people to think themselves
into that story of how prohibitions or
commands of legal systems of whatever
sort have in fact stimulated their bad
behavior yep so that's sort of part one
yes dissing Alice and then he throws in
another rhetorical question so you know
the argument is moving on to a new stage
in verse thirteen did one is good then
bring death to me by no means it was sin
working death in me through what is good
but what as good as the law the law
right in order that sin might be shown
to be sin and through the commandment
might become sinful beyond measure and
now he throws him another eye nerrit you
know I am of the flesh sold into slavery
understand here we have slavery in a
different way than it was used right in
this chapter and the eye that's speaking
here now in verses 14 and following is I
think a standard literary character we
have examples in Greek drama and in
Latin and Greek poetry about people who
had a divided will overcome their
passion and emotion to do something that
they recognized was wrong the most
famous example of that is Medea and in
the poetry of Ovid and in the place of
your repartee idea at the witch who
kills her own children even though she
sees and knows how's the the wrong
something overcome sure yeah something
overcome should overcome sir yeah so I
think anybody who was at all familiar
with with these standard characters in a
Greek drama and poetry would recognize
that they're on the way in fact this
there are passages here verse 19 for I
do not do the good I want but the evil I
do not want is what I do it's almost a
quotation from from classical sources so
Paul is conjuring up an image here of
someone who was so overcome by passion
that they cannot do what they know the
ethical system requires and that points
to what what I think is at the heart of
his his critique of
that is it's a reading of the human
condition that says there's something
inherently flawed about who we all are
he sometimes uses the language of flesh
to talk about that times the language of
passion yeah but in any case so the the
the turn of the screw or the worm in the
flashers I make something doesn't quite
work
that's right it's about our best
intentions right and so that is what it
is that finally God's gracious Act is
somehow addressing yeah and the law
can't address that the law can only
exacerbate yeah no that's nice I think
there's a I think there's an important
point in theological interpretation here
if I can do a quick parenthesis which is
that so much of Romans 7 has been read
through Martin Luther and his own sense
that that his attempt to be a righteous
person continually fell apart so that
when he reads this he reads it very
autobiographically my obedience of the
Catholic Church was not adequate to my
salvation it was only when I heard about
grace that I realized I could be at once
a sinner and justified and I the Paul we
read about elsewhere is much more robust
in his sense of self than Luther was at
that point and and I think for I think
for the Paul that I read it's not so
much that he feels like a miserable
person that I am every day is that in
the light of Jesus grace and mercy he
rethinks the things that had been
important to him and and if you read
this more as a trope as a kind of
rhetorical device about humankind and
not Paul telling us how bad he's felt
about his childhood sexual
transgressions or whatever you get a
richer sense of how he thinks gospel
works mm-hmm
yeah and I think Luther was influenced
by Agustin absolutely who also whoever
gave us the narrative yeah absolutely
yeah yeah there's a famous essay on this
Pauline introspective yes to the west by
one of my teachers Christopher yeah who
were tributes to Luther and Luther's
strong reading of this epistle kind of
miss reading a poem yeah and stand all
on others often point to passengers like
Philippians 2 where Paul gives that
robust let's be more pleased about
himself so he doesn't seem to have this
anxiety so I did I just yeah I think I
think I think we in a way if we
concentrate too much on Paul's
psychology here we miss his anthropology
we missed the way in which he's talking
about the human condition not about what
a bad life he had before he met Jesus
right so now let's think about the the
solution that Paul has proposed he says
okay the law is is in itself good it
just is not up to the deed of exactly
bringing people into a relationship with
what is good and right and true with God
and that has somehow been accomplished
through the death and resurrection of
Christ in which we participate by
baptism by which we become slaves to
righteousness etc so therefore is it
over have we in effect dealt with the
problem of sin are we new creatures
entirely are we entirely nuclear yeah
what do you think I think he's going to
tell us in Chapter 12 following why
we're not right in the chapter eight
with the okay yeah with the sense of
what we learned through the spirit
through the spear okay and I think in in
Chapter eight he's picking up on this
series of images in metaphors that he's
used for the new relationship we have
with God right and there's there as many
commentators on Paul have said there's
an already and or not yet and both of
the exactly involved in the life of the
Spirit exactly and so the spirit is is
at work in us transforming us but we are
not totally transformed as yet right and
he gives this marvelous image of the
Spirit groaning within us as it yearns
for the redemption of the body oh you
know in some ways this reminds us of
Galatians three and four where his the
the punch line of his whole argument is
the experience of the Spirit that we
currently have to baptism and he's doing
the same sort of thing here now through
baptism through the prayer life that we
have saying Abba Father
he'll allude to the same thing here we
have children around we know that we had
that relationship we know we're being
transformed but it's not done yeah yeah
I've used I don't think he hasn't mine
but I've used the Lord's Prayer in
preaching to say every time we say our
Father we are laying claim to what God
has done for us in Jesus Christ which is
to bring us into that family right Paul
allusive a father prayer of some sort
yeah verse 15
Oh Lord mother prayer its prayer first
relationship that we have with God and
what about the not yet part of it as we
as we talk about what is yet to come at
the end of chapter 8 yeah
Paul's insistence on the future glory in
verses 18 and following insists on the
night yet yeah where he recognizes the
sufferings of the present time and he
recognizes the way in which we are not
yet perfected in this relationship and
in this this moral transformation that
he sees happening through the life of
the Spirit but at the end of the day he
celebrates both the other not yet and
what is to come and as we said at the
beginning of our reflections in this bit
of poetic prose right appears at the end
of chapter 31 about God's love from
which nothing can separate I think
because right yeah and so we have that
triad built into this section of Romans
faith yeah in for hope and fire love
here at the end of eight dilma dating
this life of hope that's attested to by
the life of the Spirit within us right
and in many ways that wraps up in some
ways what he's doing in the first great
section of the epistle and prepares us
for the next set of questions which is
let's talk about Bart Israel exactly a
good way to end this session would be
just to think about that last two verses
of chapter 8
marvelous verses for I'm convinced that
neither death nor life nor Angels nor
rulers nor things present nor things to
come nor powers nor height nor depth nor
anything else in all creation will be
able to separate us from the love of God
in Christ Jesus our Lord can't beat it